- My husband Dominic
he's an amazing husband
he's a great guy
very loving, very caring.
But when fall comes around
it all suddenly changes.
(NFL music)
(whistle blows)
When football season starts.
My husband is obsessed
with football.
On Sunday's,
he barely talks to me
it's like I don't even exist.
Babe
- We have talked about this
ever since we started dating.
Sunday's aren't made for relationships.
They're made for football.
- It's not just on Sundays,
Mondays, Thursdays or
Saturdays
It's non-stop talking on
the phone about football
Can you please get off the phone?
- She makes me feel like I'm
the only guy in the world
that's into football.
But it's like,
everyone of my friends
are exactly the same way.
- I love my husband, but
honestly I can't take it anymore.
I feel like I just disappear.
- Please welcome Suchi
and her sports ball
obsessed husband Dominic.
You're not really that bad, right?
- Well...
- Oh, you hesitated. Okay
- I mean
it's been a passion since a kid.
I've always been into football
um, grew up watching
football with my father
and just something that's just embedded
(cheer from crowd)
and so, it's just a, yeah
- You got one fan here
- There we go
okay
- But the problem though,
Su-chi is more than
watching football, right?
- It's more than just
watching a football game
he's really into fantasy football.
So, he'll wake up like
(crowd cheering)
- Congratulations, two
more people on your side
- There we go, that's three
- So he'll um, he'll
wake up 5 in the morning
he'll check the status of his players
He'll call his cousins, his brother
so they're all talking on the phone
they're in the group text message, and
I basically don't get any attention or
communication.
- My God
Do you wish that Suchi would become a fan?
- Well no, I mean
I don't want her to
necessarily become a fan
I just kinda
kinda want Sundays to my, ya know the
to myself to watch football.
- So wait, you (laughs)
my favorite part was when you were like
relationships aren't
supposed to happen on Sundays
- [Dominic] Yeah I just think--
- Uh, somebody needs to tell God
- [Dominic] Right
- [Kelly] I think that's
the Lord's day, but
wait,
have you tried watching
games with Dominic?
- [Suchi] Yes, I have
I checked some YouTube Videos
I went on Google
and uh--
- [Kelly] I try and get into it too
- You know what, I did try
watching some games with him
but I just, I couldn't get into it Kelly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I find it kinda
don't hate me okay
- [Kelly] I don't have
the endurance for it.
- but I find it kinda boring.
- Me too
except, I think that they are athletes
I think that it's impressive what they do
it's just some people don't
like to chill watching
you know what I'm saying?
That's not my vibe.
That's not me either, but..
So, ladies any of your guys
any of your guys like this?
They're not?
- I feel like my fiance,
he played football
and did track, and like
very, very athletic
and he loves football
his whole family loves football
so what I do, is when he's like
I am non-existent when games are on
I just go sit in the tub and
prune
and just have a great time
have some wine
go book a massage, I'm like
Oh, you wanna keep that day for you?
I will do a me day.
It'll be great, you know.
- [ Kelly] Oh my gosh, I'm with you.
- A little balance
- I have no idea what fantasy football is.
- Yeah, she doesn't do sports, so
- But, how long does it last?
How many months out of the year?
- [Dominic] Well, five and a half.
- Five and a half. Oh, Okay.
I was just about to say if it's two months
then
wait it out. But five, I don't know.
(laughing)
- So wait, how has this impacted
ya'lls relationship Suchi
- Basically our quality time
especially when I come
home from a long day
at work
I wanna be able to talk to him about it
he's my best friend, so I
I just love spending time with him
talking to him about everything
but, I know at times he
pretends like he's listening
it just goes in and out the other ear
(laughing)
- I feel like that's men in general
- [Kelly] I was like
That's called being married, but yeah
that will happen without football
- Yeah, exactly.
- That's true, yeah.
- But how does that make you feel
I mean, do you think you could give up
like one day?
- I mean, I--
- Cause it's a lotta, there's like
it's not just Thursday, or
just Monday
it's all the days, I feel like.
- Well, fantasy, I mean you're
constantly checking updates
so fantast is pretty much everyday.
Sunday, the games are on all day,
of course you have Monday night football
and Thursday.
- [Kelly] (laughs) oh, my God!
You should be a commentator.
- Yeah.
- That's amazing
Okay, so would you mind, Dominic
if maybe like I helped her
find something to do on Sundays
- No, I'm totally open to it.
I mean, yeah.
- He's like, please!
- Yeah, I'm totally open to it
- [Kelly] All right, all right.
- I think I've always
had an interest for dance
especially Hip-Hop, so
I wouldn't mind taking some dance classes.
- [Kelly] All right, Suchi.
Some Hip-Hop
I just pictured you in a club.
It was awsome.
(laughing)
It was awesome.
Well, I've got someone here
who can teach you all about dancing
you know him from his time
on Dancing With The Stars
I'm so excited about this
please welcome
Maksim Chmerkovskiy!
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my God!
- Woo, look at that outfit!
- You look so cute!
- Do ya'll mind scootin' down?
Okay
I love that you brought my wardrobe!
- Right
- That's my wardrobe, that's
so weird that you have..
No really, what is that?
Is that, is that for her?
- [Maksim] It's um, yeah.
So, first of all I have to say that we
thank you for having me
- Oh my gosh, we're excited
- We have absolutely nothing to do
I've never met them before
- Oh my God, look at ya'll!
- We're sitting like this, like
- [Kelly] This is a match made in heaven!
- I'm just saying, if
you're gonna go with it
just go all out.
You know what I'm saying
- Yeah
Like go both halves
- Right
(laughing)
- This right here
this, believe it or not this is a dress.
- Oh wow
- Not in my closet, but yes.
- In my wife's closet
there's a few of those.
- okay, I wanna be your wife
- I think that we're gonna talk about
what I'm doing here
- Yes
- So I figured that
- Is that for Suchi?
- This is for Suchi.
- Okay
- Girl
- Uh-oh (laughs)
- This is for Suchi
- Not only is this for Suchi but,
- [Kelly] Wait, all of a sudden
- All of a sudden
Dominic is like, football what?
- [Dominic] Yeah (laughs)
- He's like wait, what
- No, but I think
I think its the right
thing to offer alternatives
you know what I'm saying?
Like I also love football, Dominic.
But I also love the fact that, you know
I mean, I can't
deny
Peta, for example, her time
on Sundays right
so we, you know, we figure things out
I don't play fantasy cause it
takes up a lot of time
What I wanna offer
(clapping)
What I wanna offer Suchi is that
you know, during the time on Sundays
when you feel a little kind of like
well what do I do
I would like to, you know
be your Sunday's partner
if you know what I'm saying?
- [Suchi] Aww, thank you!
(cheering) (clapping)
- So what's your dance plan?
I'm so excited!
- [Maksim] So, I have a plan
because I feel like
you know, I feel like
this is the hobby that
you were looking forward to.
First of all this dance,
this dress is gonna be
hopefully on you by the time we're done
cause we're gonna prepare
an amazing, sexy, hot dance routine
That you're gonna dance on this show
- [Dominic] Oh, wow
(cheering)
- That's what I'm talkin about
How does that sound!
- [Maksim] How does that sound?
- [Suchi] exciting!
- Are you excited!
- Yes, I am!
Oh my gosh!
- We're gonna come up with
something hot and sexy
obviously, you know,
fitting for this
whatever the thing
this thing is
- [Kelly] It's a dress, apparently
- I'm a bit confused how you put it on
but it's a dress
I have a group of amazing
uh, to look at and learn from
dancers
that are uh, gonna be working with you
the performance here on this show
is not gonna be our last performance
it's gonna be kinda like a
a, um, a
test run if you will for
the big grand performance
which is, that you and I are
gonna dance at one of the
Super Bowl parties in Miami
this coming Super Bowl weekend
- [Kelly] Did you hear that?
She's going to the Super Bowl, Dominic!
- I do have to say, I was told that
I'm your plus one,
so he can't come, so
it's gonna be just the two of us
But you can watch us on Sundays
cause that's, you know
that's what happens
- That's amazing!
- You'll love it
- I'm like going on this side
- I am loving it
I am loving it
I think it sounds awesome
- No, it sounds great
- It's irony at it's finest.
- [Suchi] Sounds like he's jealous
- Listen, at the end of this
the idea is, that maybe Dominic
be okay, you know what I'm saying,
I'm gonna join this.
This is, this has to be us.
- Yeah, no I--
- I guarantee if you put
that on he would join you
(laughing)
- Yeah, no. That's a good alternative.